[Music]
i don't think that makes me
simple-minded
so you're a simple-minded man and i have
a story for you
simple-minded man okay so this story
here is actually really cute
so this girl she got hired
and after she got hired at this new job
during a pandemic which right now times
are [ __ ] tough right right
so she got hired at this place that's a
bar and grill in georgia
and then after she walked out from
getting the job
she had a really cute reaction that was
caught on cctv
i think i saw this one yeah and then her
boss
posted it on twitter or tick tock and
then it went viral
so here it's super cute
what was this again she just got a job
oh wow straight up celebration like a
movie but why didn't i
look at that walk but why did she do it
in the handicapped spa we know that they
need those flags
it was empty he was so [ __ ] crazy
well no but you know that somebody could
have been pulling in and they see that
and like [ __ ] i can't even park
victory dancing there what was the job
dad that's so cute we don't know
exactly what position but i thought it
was a cable company no it's it's a bar
and grill
a sports bar and grill i just saw that
that van and it looked like a cable
company so i was like
she's got hired at 18 tears those are
good jobs
it doesn't matter the point is she got a
job hey all i'm saying is pandemic i
love
how she looked both ways look she looks
like anyone watching me
nah the walk after two is my favorite
where she walks away very professional
look at that
nothing happened what are you talking
about nice recovery yeah is it her first
job
i don't know if it's her first job but
times are tough so she got caught
so here yeah she did so here is the girl
and then this is the boss who's the girl
that was parting the left
oh did she try to excuse it after they
caught her she's like oh no there's gum
in my shoe i'm just like i'm just like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] gum on my [ __ ] she
didn't realize she was being seen until
the next day
when the boss told her you're going
viral on tick tock
oh damn someone there posted it no the
boss yeah
like she already posted and she's like
you are already viral not you're going
to be
[Laughter]
she's like i did this without your
permission yes yes yes
that's that's a good video to go viral
for there's a lot worse things to get
viral on yeah you can't even tell who it
is yeah so she captioned it
so i just hired this young girl and this
was her response yeah that's so cute
why would she walk her go to the parking
lot walk her to the parking lot why was
she watching her go to the parking lot
oh
i know right i mean the security footage
is probably
like the interview is still ongoing
like she was like i'm gonna see how she
exits this interview oh
she's very thorough yeah like does she
punch a car window on the way
out what does she do we're getting the
job i'm gonna flip my place off
like she turns around [ __ ] you [ __ ]
she just like how does that plan work
out like if you expect
that reaction wouldn't that mean she
didn't get the job but then you're
expecting that reaction out of girl who
did get well no no yeah because some
people have bad attitudes so if they got
a job
even if they don't they don't want to
work technically so they're like
[ __ ] this establishment anyway but i'm
just saying she got a really good swag
dance
yeah and you know this is this is
another one of those affirmation moments
where it's just like it doesn't matter
if you can dance
you recognize that it is used to express
very very emotional that's coming from a
dancer in case you didn't know
he's a dancer a professional dancer do
you think that that's the dance she
would have gone with had she known she
was being recorded though oh
good point she might have been facing
the camera okay okay
have you done a seductive dance for your
significant other
this took a crazy turn uh yeah yeah have
you actually
yeah i actually have is that like a chip
and dales can you do it without laughing
because i can't
every time i try or like we try to try
to seduce each other
what do you do you give him a lap dance
or you let her it only gets really funny
when like
you're naked yeah that's that's when
it's hilarious
when you yeah when you get to to that
it's entertaining it's not like
hilarious but when you get to like the
balls are out it's there's no way it's
not funny because dicks and balls should
not bounce around like that it's just
ridiculous
one more time yeah they're flopping well
one has different inertia than the other
the bruno one
the bruno remember bruno but then the
balls are doing something different you
know so it's like that
depends on how warm it
it just is not alluring when you look at
it yeah it's not alluring no
i like that word yeah do girls like a
sexy dance
i mean i've never gotten one cause it's
always funny dance
when you never watched it at the chip
and diesel oh i did get a chippendale
dancing right
i got pulled up on stage you got the nut
on your face like this
they did not do that but i was really
seduced
i was like oh my god what was seductive
about it yeah i'm taking notes
the hotness of it it was just seductive
but what part of it describe it okay so
they would do this like grinding motion
where i'm like
oh because i saw him do that to you next
to the microwave and you did not have
that reaction oh because i was in the
middle of pouring a shot
hello that's really funny i
we've been doing it for three days
straight we have it is a daily task i
feel like of all the times
in a day pouring a shot might be the
time to like begin not being elected but
not
like it was appropriate no job was like
hey let's get you going like this she's
like
[ __ ] [ __ ] casey i can't i can't
[ __ ] pour this
she's like nah she's trying to pour a
drink in an suv going off-road and [ __ ]
like
she said the grind it wasn't a [ __ ]
thank you
people don't understand that yes it's
not [ __ ] jack hammering way
it's a grind yeah like it's
like a hawaiian ocean not during the
winter so
less masculine my like my man here more
feminine is what you wanted
a little more feminine energy yeah okay
this guy was [ __ ] coming at you like
a construction worker
that's not sexy don't do that do not do
that
that's unless you're at the end of can
you do that
in eight minutes and 20 seconds into the
pumping
why is it specifically start
jackhammering in
later yeah yeah yeah 10 seconds is the
the slow how long how much uh oh slow
motion ocean [ __ ] do we
need to do as men before we get into
this stage of well every session
is different too how much my memory
how long do we have to be moms for how
many macarenas do we have to do
[Laughter]
before we can do what we want to do how
many macarenas do we have to do until we
get to
it's not about how many you do it's
about how you do it
i told you he's a dancer he's a dancer
oh there you go
hey macarena
i um i thought it was funny to to to uh
do the sexy dance because um like a lot
of ladies say that they just go there
for like
comedy purposes not really to get like
horny horny i got a friend who goes out
to get horny really
i'm not kidding she [ __ ] loves
chipping nails she gets [ __ ] wet as
[ __ ]
geez yeah and she's she brings her
friends to it because she thinks it's
like the next thing
that's kind of sad but wait is that like
isn't it fair to just be like of course
you're going for the entertainment but
of course you're going because it's
stimulating a very very clear
element of your entertainment because it
does stimulate that right
right yeah so like and that's there's
nothing wrong with it but no no but like
the fact like how
how thirsty she is for it is like a
little thirsty or honest
oh both but but okay no because she's
dragging other people that's the thirsty
part
but both because she wants other people
to experience it with her too but also
what's interesting about it i think is
that afterwards she's very horny for her
man
so it's like it kind of helps so that's
awesome it's just how we are with strip
clubs i think
that works right right so her man's just
like hey don't you want to
there's extra tickets to this show
tonight feel free we got tickets every
night we got the premiere pack best [ __ ]
is that her
is just at home on the lazy boy watching
tv and [ __ ] she's getting all turned on
out there he doesn't have to [ __ ]
deal with it and then she comes home all
turned on as [ __ ] and then he can do
whatever so i'm saying he gets her a
season pass to like the show you know
right they don't have that say hey i got
a box at chippendales that's funny
wow that's a good idea right dude you
ever been to a strip club and then
you're horny after and you [ __ ] your
chick well that would
be well okay i'm gonna stop right there
but yes that would be appropriate answer
your question yes yeah
absolutely i have it's [ __ ] great it
gets you turned on you're not
necessarily turned on for the chick it's
just the sexuality of everything that's
happening
after being committed a relationship i
never go to the strip club to get horny
i always go only if there's like a
virgin dude who's never been to a ship
club therefore he needs his escort
as a friend and it just turns into a
comedy show there's never been a
situation where it's like let's go to
the strip club because i want to get
horny and then like go home and do
something about it it's always just like
you've never been [ __ ] now we gotta
go i go because i'm fascinated with the
strippers
life so i like to buy lap dances and i
ask them if they're really a student or
not paying for their
school what do they answer they lie they
say that they love him and that they
want to be
saved yeah they say that i'm um special
because they never get young guys
and then like i never get young cute
ones yeah and i always hear that
over and over and over so i'm like have
you ever fallen in love with the
stripper he has many times well it's
really they fall in love with him
actually
oh right right there it is i don't even
go my branding sucks man because i don't
even go
that much and i don't even care about
that [ __ ] own it own your brand
no yes
[Laughter]
dude i have a friend who um he was like
uh
okay so he he never had much attention
from women right so like he went to this
special
strip club in mexico yeah
well he's very lonely so he went to this
one in mexico right and it's a very
hong kong yeah really that's the one
that i went to and i got front
credit carded i got to see this hong
kong what are you talking about they
just come up and go like that so the guy
at the door
who seems to be like an owner or
whatever because he was some chinese
dude and
he like i was leaving and he just goes
like my vagina lips are like this and he
goes
and then does he like with his feet
hands yeah like this
he just went like this to me is he like
your car got to climb this
sorry i gotta run in the game i have to
run it again listen this doesn't always
happen
that's not cool dude that was straight
up sexual harassment sexual law
that's assault i felt [ __ ] violated
maybe he thought you were one of the
workers there
i was wearing pants maybe he thought you
were one of the workers there i was
i was i was i'm not justifying it i'm
just saying what a weird
place did you complain my wife is hot
you complain about it
did you do anything about it i was so
shocked i was so
shocked and we were leaving we were
literally walking away from the strip
club and then like that happened i was
like
did that just happen and i was already
like that's why he does it because he
gets away with it
that's [ __ ] up that's super [ __ ] up
like literally he went [ __ ] if you
were wearing a skirt
that would have been worse anyway back
to your story i would have washed my
[ __ ] with bleach after that but
[ __ ] dirty ass touched my pants
destroy your [ __ ] though yeah but hey
it's worth it i don't want his [ __ ]
dirty face let's go find him let's go
let's go to tj let's go find him oh yeah
let's go to hong kong
that's your strategy yeah let's go we
need to go
he's the owner we're here hey baby let's
just
just fix in your face like we're here
for your revenge
yeah we're like hold on we gotta we
gotta act
not suspicious so we better get lap
dances dude dude that was the same place
it was the most high class place in
adelitas which is a whole street of
strip club it's supposed to be the best
one that's the one where i saw the foam
stage
it was like all foam and then this chick
had dollars going in and out of her
[ __ ] it was crazy anyway
you told me about that that's tight
that's nuts a dollar is strong enough to
go in
and out in and out how tight did they
roll it the guy was going
oh it wasn't even rolled up it was like
a flaccid bill
what was her vagina
atmosphere he was sticking it in and
then getting it out with his mouth he
was getting it up
anyway oh so everyone knows the stripper
game right you're a special boy
no matter who you are never met anyone
especially if you're simpy
so they always say the same thing it's
like oh something about
you it's so different or whatever they
got a game going on i usually don't do
this but yeah i usually don't i'm not
you know
yeah i'm really a student in my other
life or like i got kids or whatever
they try to play on those or i got kids
they're playing a game right
so like they went off script right so
yeah so he was like yeah
so she was like she really liked me so
she was on my lap
and then like you know i had to pay her
so then like
she doesn't go to other guys but it was
because like her boss you know she she
made her but she kept playing with my
hair she kept telling me how like
i like she likes me the best and then
like she took a nap on me it was super
sweet
and i'm all like bro you let her
sleep on the job because you thought she
liked you no [ __ ] no it's different man
i have long hair and she was like
playing with my long hair and she really
was like oh your hair's so cool
and then like i think i'm gonna go back
and visit her because like she really
liked me and then when she woke up
she's like hey i gotta charge you for
four hours or my boss will get pissed
and so that's literally what it is i
love this guy
yes in a movie can we honestly just
follow him with the documentary film
crew
yeah i want to follow guys who fall in
love with strippers yeah dude that's
documented
he no he wouldn't listen to anybody it
was like 90 day fiance and he's getting
catfished i was like telling this [ __ ]
like
she doesn't like you man he's like oh
you just hating man
you don't know man you know man we had a
[ __ ] connection
you might as well flip this girl you
should be like yo dude she likes you
you couldn't barely hear her over the
music dude she was different i should
have done it he deserved it but imagine
all of the strippers around the world
that are like
man how come they always think i don't
love them
that's good that's good there's a chance
my heart breaks every night yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you